[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is Aran and I'll be
your host today without further Ado
let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together
today's topic will be about Teen Mental
Health in high school where we will be
discussing the many factors that play a
role in Teen Mental Health
and share strategies to help high school
students cope with their
challenges in today's podcast we will
cover many segments one of them being
social media and peer
pressure social media in today's modern
age has had quite a significant impact
in our lives but aside from social media
we have another factor that has affected
Our Lives which is peer pressure peer
pressure is the process by which members
of the same social class influence other
members to do things that they may be
reluctant to do this term is usually
used in a negative way
symbolizing things in which peers do for
example drugs or
alcohol uh teens are more vulnerable to
peer pressure because they are in a
stage where they are separating more
from their parents and have their own
critical thinking of the world and human
relations uh many teens
are um dependent of peer pressures since
they want social acceptance and they are
willing to do anything to get accepted
in a group or by their peers for example
even doing drugs or things that they
know that aren't good but still do them
despite the fact that peer fresh is
usually associated with bad situations
it can sometimes be beneficial for
example positive peer
pressure in positive peer pressure we
can take the example of two students one
of them starts going to the gym and
starting healthy habits and the other
doesn't but since his friend does he
takes up the gym and starts doing
healthy habits for his own
benefit this can be seen as positive
peer pressure but in the long run and if
done
repeatedly uh very often it can cause
exercise addition where the individual
neglects all other tasks and just finds
physical activity as a way of coping
with his
problems uh now we're going to talk
about ways
to treat peer pressure for us not to
have as much we as it does on our lives
and and some of the ways to uh stop this
is by parental influence and emotional
intelligence what do I mean by parental
influence is that if a child has a more
positive and comforting environment he
will of course be more Comfort
comfortable with telling his parents
everything that is happening and the
parents can also be a role model for
emotional
self-regulation emotional self-re ation
is when the individual has the ability
to control thoughts emotions and urges
this is related to emotional
intelligence as stated above which can
also help into the student thinking
rationally and to consider why is he
doing these negative things and set
boundaries for example to stay with
certain people of high class and not to
stay with people that
do uh things that can
cause negative effects on their
lives the second segment that we're
going to talk about that causes stress
on teens is
extracurricular
activities since high school students
tend to grow up and during this time
they find their goals and purpose in
life they tend to hone the skills in the
particular field that they want to
develop and that is
made that is made possible
by extra cicular
activities these activities help us
develop as individuals but a downside is
that it consumes a lot of our time and
when our time is consumed we don't know
which part to juggle which one to focus
on and that causes quite a lot of stress
for us
teenagers time is money is a well-known
quote used by many people and it
expresses the value of
time but is the value of time really
that like the
money uh many philosophers state that
time is our life hence it has way more
value than money and US teenagers don't
know how to juggle these many activities
and that's why we tend to do all of them
but in the end we still are
stressed in a way we are wasting our
lives
in overworking ourselves instead of
trying to focus on just one task at a
time um in a study researchers found out
that time management makes us way more
productive and has a strong impact on
life
satisfaction and this is way more
important than job satisfaction since
even though you do your job you're not
as productive as you should be when you
are happy and have quite a happy
lifestyle a healthy
lifestyle um though there are many books
for time management I don't think that
they should be applied in today's modern
age since I think that there should be
no shortcuts shortcuts in any of the
task that we do we don't need need those
we just need
to have a better understanding of what's
important to us and which task can we
neglect more so I think that in order to
have a nice time management there need
to be
sacrifices and so we can achieve a
peaceful
mind another segment that is related to
teen m mental health is self-care and
coping
strategies as we mentioned before uh
teenagers are affected by many things
that take a toll on their mental health
whether that being peer pressure or
stress
um for that there are many coping
techniques that us teenagers can do
firstly a way that helped me become more
aware of the task at hand and help me in
managing my time is developing a morning
routine although it is neglected and
seen as as seen as not necessary a
morning routine can help people in many
ways a morning routine can help you be
more aware of the task at hand and you
are more organized as an individual for
a morning routine we can have many ways
to develop this but there is a practice
called eat the
Frog where the question is made like
this if you're going to have dinner and
you're going to have to eat a frog will
you eat the Frog before dinner or after
dinner many people will say before
dinner and this uh translate to this
morning routine as well where we do the
hard tasks first and then we can uh
focus on the other tasks at hand and
even have time to uh relax after the
tasks done and another way to deal with
stress and anxiety is to be aware of our
emotions and be able to control them as
mentioned
before uh emotional
intelligence this can emotional
intelligence can be won by meditation
meditation may seem a bit silly at first
by Our Generation but it is beneficial
for us in many ways since it's a way to
relax our thoughts our racing thoughts
and be able to organize our emotions and
not let them get the best of
us and this is the end of the podcast uh
and thank you so much for joining us on
this episode it's been an incredible
journey and we're so glad you came along
for the ride until next time take
[Music]
care